de façon de réviser pour un même
objectif le baccalauréat au centre
alfred de vigny à voisins le bretonneux
ambiance petit comité
tout ce qui traite des nombres complexes
avec les numéros des baquets les numéros
des exercices donc talent points à
l'exercice 3
eurêka c'est l'opération de soutien
scolaire mise en place par l'association
de petits groupes de travail accompagnés
par des professeurs c'est des stages de
six heures donc ces trois séances de
deux heures l'activité ici avec à
commence à face au centrafrique et vini
a commencé non on a commencé le 28 août
avec les stages de prérentrée puis on a
fait toute l'année scolaire
ici les élèves sont aidés en france et
en physique ou en mathématiques
eureka semble bien accueillie c'était
pour bien acquérir les dernières notion
ce qui manque est comblé les petites
lacunes défunt à montigny le bretonneux
du soutien amical
jules en terminale s a choisi de réviser
avec ses amis correction dans l'action
il les retrouve tous les jours dans une
bibliothèque objectif révisé la physique
une épreuve qui compte coefficient 9 on
est beaucoup plus productif à plusieurs
en fait il ya toute une ambiance tout ça
donc
alors on peut discuter forcément c'est
obligé mais mais en même temps ça nous
oblige à travailler et ça nous permet
aussi bas si on a des problèmes des
questions de
demander directement à l'image de jules
et des autres 750 3148 candidats débute
le bac lundi ces révisions portant
ont-elles leurs fruits
réponse le 6 juillet prochain